what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I give my
thoughts over my green tea I quit coffee
but anyways before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell that we are going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and subscribe
to the channel so
um first things first this is not a
hickey I want to go close just so you
can see I burnt my neck
trying to learn to curl my hair I'm
really not
girly or I've been learning to be more
girly
and it's been a journey let me tell you
and yeah the next anyways it doesn't
matter
um so today I want to talk about
how my life has improved in the past
year
so
a year ago I would say maybe two years
ago when I came to England I grew up as
a tomboy I was the biggest tomboy and I
still am like you don't just it doesn't
just go away right
but about two years ago I really wanted
to
um put more of an effort into my
appearance and the way that I look
and I'm not going to say I'm perfect
right A lot of people want you to just
change from zero to 100 overnight but
let me just give you guys a little
sneak peek into how I dressed a year ago
all right this is a screenshot
now
there's still room for improvement my
hair I need to learn I'm learning I'm
learning how to do hair
but
it's crazy how much better about
yourself you feel when you're actually
working towards a goal and when you
don't know that something's a problem
how can you improve on it and what I
realized was that my appearance the way
that I dressed
um looking homeless all the time was a
problem and I realized that I
embarrassed my family
now not my dad my dad doesn't care about
that stuff but
that that doesn't matter
um
so so
um the other thing that I improved upon
was I was
um I lost like
I've been kind of stagnant but about a
year and a half ago I was 15 to 20
pounds heavier
and I've been able to lose 10 to 15
pounds and keep it off now I'd like to
lose a little more I'm not saying but
you always feel better when you're
around people that have the same goals
in you or that are actively working to
pursue those goals
um about two or three years ago I was
working in a sales job that I hated and
now I get the freedom
of
doing something that I love
and
uh and I'm not saying that there's no
other areas of my life that need to
improve there are but
when you're around people that are
getting better you feel better and you
start to realize how important your
circle is and how much people influence
you around you
um and which is why to me it's been so
incredibly hard for me to be away from
my family
um because
you know like that's that's who you
should be like your number one influence
should be and that's why it's so
important as women that we build
families with men that have strong
values and a good moral compass because
genuinely I don't know where I would be
without my dad
um and I can't even imagine what it's
like to like not have that backbone
um
so
the other thing
um that I realized while watching like
manosphere and red pill content is how
important respect is to men
and I think at times in my life I I can
be rude I think you guys have seen I can
be a bit rude
um I would say I'm polite but if you if
I
I can be rude okay let's just let's just
call a spade a spade and my little
brother Adam was your typical like I
would say Alpha guy like he's just a
natural-born leader and it's his way or
the highway and a lot of people in my
family when especially when he was
younger had trouble
getting along with Adam
and
the problem
because you know it's like it's your
little brother like I don't want to
listen to my little brother but my
relationship changed with Adam when one
day I just said you know what I'm gonna
listen
and that's what I did I just listened to
what he said now I'm not 100 I'm Still
Human but
when I started to treat like when I
started to realize how great my little
brother is like genuinely this is
something I Believe In My Soul of souls
my little brother is the most helpful
kid he is going to be a
multi-billionaire and I genuinely
believe that he
people he he can also be rude a bit
rough on the edges at times but he will
go like to the ends of the Earth to help
you more than anyone in my family
and before I would focus on him being
rude or him being like other negative
traits about which he has everyone has
negative traits but when I started
focusing on what he did right I realized
I started treating him differently and I
just started to feel differently about
him too and it made me realize how much
your perception of people is in your
control where if you actively look to
seek out like what people do right as
opposed to nitpicking at what they do
wrong
um
how much better your relationships can
be
and there was another time in my life
where
my dad um I didn't really realize how
much he did for me
and I remember I was mad because my dad
was out of town when I was younger and a
lot of people throw this in my face
they'll be like you guys had nannies we
had 10 kids
most of the time most of the times the
nannies were just like for driving
because
we all did all these different sports
everywhere
um but what I realized with my dad when
I started appreciating my dad
and speaking highly of him more and
really looking up to him and I just and
I genuinely in my school so I look up to
both my brother and my dad
um
my relationship with them got better
and some of this wasn't like active like
I wasn't watching some of this was while
I was watching manosphere content some
wasn't it just happened naturally like
but
I realized how important respect is to
men and if you want to be with men you
have to look up to them and respect them
um so
the next lesson that I learned was about
forgiveness
um
and this this is something I still
struggle with because I do get I do get
mad
and I'm not the type to get actively
like angry with someone right like I'm
not gonna scream I'm not gonna that's
just not my personality but at times I
have trouble letting things go
hey and um
an example of this I'm going to use with
one of my sisters so a couple years ago
one of my sisters and I wait this is
when we were way younger so I hope she
doesn't get mad at me telling my story
but me and her got into a fight like a
really big fight when we were younger
and I was so angry at her for so long
okay like I was pissed I was so angry
and
um
I really didn't talk to her for
for years to be honest like I just I
yeah and what I realized was
that hurt me more than it hurt her and
it probably hurt her too but
I realized that my inability at the time
to forgive people
would get in the way of relationships
with family with relationships with with
people
um and I had to really look in and
figure out how to forgive
and anytime you get mad about something
that happened in the past just to remind
yourself that was the past it doesn't
matter move forward and it's not an easy
mindset to have
and the the most
and I realized that no matter how much
you tell someone all the things they did
no matter how much you
like say this hurt that hurt that hurt
Nothing's Gonna fix it and all you can
really do is figure out how to get along
moving forward assuming you want a
relationship with that person I mean
some people are too toxic you can't have
relationships with them fine but it's
like if you want to be with someone what
is the point of holding on to all that
anger it's like you either forgive them
and move forward or you don't forgive
them and you cut it off but even if you
cut it off I actually still recommend
forgiveness because and I'll tell you
another story
so I have an ex-boyfriend of mine that
it ended poorly it ended very bad
and
I was really really angry for a long
time about it
I was very angry
and
what I realized was that by holding on
to that anger I was hurting myself again
hurting myself more than him because at
that point I blocked him I didn't want
to speak to him again whatever
and I had I had a good reason to be in
all honesty but it doesn't at the end of
the day it doesn't matter what your
reason is
anger hurts you and holding on to anger
and things that people have done hurts
you
and
practicing forgiveness like improves
your mental health and
makes your relationships better and I'll
tell you the day that I really felt
better about that relationship and let
things go was the day I unblocked him I
called him and I said I forgive you
um I'm not mad I'm sorry for my part to
play
and then I listed the things that I'm
gonna keep to myself that I I did wrong
to
um
um yeah so
that's my two cents of like things that
I've learned in life is that the more
forgiving of a person you can be the
more you get out of life and the more
selfless you you can be the more you get
out of life and this is something I've
also noticed with women the women that
will say I did so much for him are the
women that are keeping score and those
aren't the women you want because the
women and I I'd like to say and all all
honesty I've been that girl but
when you're when you're keeping score
with men and counting all the things
that you're you're doing it's just not
a healthy relationship and it's not
um
a place where
when you're keeping score oftentimes
you're looking at what you did and
you're not looking at what all the stuff
they do for you and I promise you you're
missing something because we don't
notice all the things that men do for us
on a day to day and men don't
necessarily want credit they don't
necessarily want
um
I don't know the glory of it I guess
so
yeah
yeah so
um I don't know that's that's just sorry
these are very random but that's my two
cents guys
um
forgiveness
holding on to past things
oh oh and the other thing about being
selfless is everybody around you loves
you so much more like the people that
are really selfless that and
um
I think of it because we had a Maggie
The Substitute Teacher come and that
woman was just so selfless oh my gosh
she spent the whole time cooking she
spent the whole time like just oh my
gosh doing the most for everyone in the
best way and what I realized is that's
how
she's gotten so much like she's in a
relationship with the man she loves
respects and admires she's been married
it's like
and I'm sure the people around her just
like love her and that's what I realized
is the girls that say that I did too
much
um they're not giving to give they're
giving to get and the people that give
to get end up unhappy and the people
that give to give end up more happy so
um
that's that's my two cents things I've
learned
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time